i'm emily compagno i'm guy benson i'm
shannon breme and this
is the fox news rundown
wednesday may 12 2021 i'm lisa brady
for some parents remote learning has
been a crash course on what their kids
are being taught
could that make school choice a campaign
issue i think the more
parents are aware of all of these
options the more they might want to
elect someone who
gives them the opportunity to make a
choice we speak with fox's martha
mccallum
i'm chris foster china's population
growth has slowed down but
not its global ambitions i think there's
a big
uncertainty around to what extent
population
is going to continue to be the primary
driver
of a country's power and i'm jim daly
i've got the final word on the fox news
rundown
[Music]
getting america vaccinated against covet
19 has consumed
just about everything for months now and
it's not over yet we have to make it
easier and more convenient for
all americans to get vaccinated you're
busting your neck doing that president
biden thanking a bipartisan group of
governors during a virtual meeting on
tuesday
and rolling out new efforts including
free uber and lyft rides to get a shot
and a partnership with mcdonald's to
promote the we can do this campaign
but mass vaccination hasn't reopened all
schools in fact the administration has
faced more questions
about how much influence the teachers
unions have
after emails suggesting union input in
cdc guidelines
the objective is to have a better
understanding of implementation
how it would work white house
spokeswoman jensaki telling reporters
they heard from a variety of
organizations about the return to
in-person learning
but in some districts what kids are
learning has taken center stage
as a new curriculum sparks intense
debate
a lot of families when their kids were
home zoom
learning which in many places they still
are in fact
i spoke with betsy devos to the former
secretary of education
and she told me that 98 of students in
california are still learning from home
martha mccallum is host of the story on
fox news channel and the untold story
podcast
so one of the interesting outgrowths of
all of this
zoom learning was that a lot of parents
got a closer look at exactly what their
kids were learning in school
and some of what they saw they some of
them
didn't like very much and so now that
a lot of kids are going back to school a
lot of parents are
questioning whether or not they approve
of some of what's being taught and that
has brought the entire issue of the 1619
project and critical race theory
into the conversation across the country
so
on the one side it's great that kids are
going back to school on the other side
some parents aren't really that happy
with what's going on in their school
and one place where it come to a head is
in texas
in a small district in texas you had two
school board members who
won overwhelming school board elections
running on a platform of eliminating
critical race theory from the classroom
and you also have some governors across
the country
in idaho and montana and oklahoma who
have
set us against the law to teach critical
race theory in
schools across the country so it's it's
getting a lot of
attention i think there's a little bit
of a tide turning
on this at least in terms of people's
understanding of what's going on
i guess part of the driving force behind
the debate
is that you know it's one thing to want
more inclusion and to want to
kind of look at things differently and
with a more open mind if you will
but then the argument against this is
really that it's going too far
that it's making uh you know white kids
feel like they're
inherently racist or that the country is
inherently racist
yeah that's that's exactly right and
the issue is that the 1619 project
lays out an alternative view of the
founding of the country
it bases it in a need or a desire
on the part of the colonists and the
first
americans or the first settlers who
colonized america and then
the declaration of independence and the
founders it takes it away from
that and moves it more to a question of
coming
to this country in order to preserve
slavery
and one scholar gordon wood who has
studied this
time period extensively writes that
there's
no evidence that the colonists were that
that was a primary motivating factor
for them coming to this country and
beginning this country
that at the same time in great britain
there was an
effort to end slavery and
that was not something that was spoken
about written about made part of the
desire
to to come and and begin a new country
and we also know that during 1776 there
was a debate about slavery
and about wanting to end slavery in this
country
and the question of whether or not they
could get through
the declaration of independence and
constitution process if they made it
part of that document
and there were strong feelings that they
should make it part of that document and
we know that it came later and there's a
lot of
understandable historical debate over
why that was and why it wasn't done
earlier in the process but to suggest
that the country
is is founded on a desire to preserve
slavery
has been called out as just simply
historically inaccurate and so i think
that obviously you want
accurate teaching to our students and
you want them to
not necessarily view the nation as
founded and steeped in something evil as
its foundational prospect
because i think there's a lot of
evidence to the contrary when you
pressed
the american federation of teachers
president randy weingarten about this
do you favor teaching students that 16
19 is more important than 1776 do you
favor that
she didn't really answer that question
directly
but i'm wondering if talking to her gave
you any new perspective on this
i was a bit taken aback that she
was simplistic about her interpretation
of what it is
she suggested that teaching the 1619
project
and i pointed out that there are
educational materials and curriculum
materials that have been
sent to schools across the country and
in fact grant money
has been linked to the usage of some of
these materials
serious by the biden administration so
it's very much
an element of curriculum that's being
considered across the country
but she suggested that it was simply
acknowledging that the first slave ship
came here in 1619 which i don't think
there's a lot of debate about i think
that
obviously is part of history it's an
acknowledged part of history it's the
larger questions that she sort of
ignored and then she said we have to
teach 1619 and 1776. so
we know that those two things are in
conflict
or the 1776 founding is
questioned by the 1619 project so it
seemed that she just
had a very simplistic view of what's
being
taught and what's part of that program
that i don't think reflects the reality
of of what the program argues
do you think that president biden will
face more questions
at some point about union influence the
way
the cdc director recently did because
that's been a part of
you know recent debates about what's
happening in schools as well
i think it's clear that the teachers
unions have an
enormous amount of influence at the
white house that they
dictated quite a bit in terms of
keeping schools closed if you remember
the cdc director
rachel richarlinsky pardon me said
that she felt that it was safe to reopen
the schools and that
teachers didn't necessarily have to be
vaccinated for kids to go back
and that was quickly followed up by the
white house saying that she was speaking
in her personal capacity when she said
that
not as the head of cdc which was a
difficult
argument to make given the fact that she
was sitting with an entire cdc wall
backdrop behind her when she was saying
this
but it was clear that they wanted to
rein that in
and i also think based on what we know
it's logical to assume
that the unions were not happy with her
saying that in that interview because we
know that they have felt very strongly
that
teachers needed to have the option to
not return to school
based on what they say is science and
yet it runs aground when you look at the
science that we've seen in terms of the
extremely low transmission rates in
school environments so
i think that it is safe to say that
there's quite a bit of influence
that the unions have in the white house
i think they were very frustrated that
they didn't have much influence at all
in the prior administration
but certainly they do have a lot of
influence now we've seen it
will these kinds of school issues and i
guess this is one of those million
dollar
questions um potentially affect
the midterm elections for instance maybe
republicans
would talk more about school choice i
think
that's absolutely true i spoke with
betsy devos about that
to former education secretary she's been
a long time advocate of school choice
and one of the interesting outcomes from
the past year has been a
greater interest in having more choices
because you saw catholic schools
reopening you saw
charter schools in many cases reopening
private schools reopening
so depending on people's ability to pay
for those options
they were choosing them if they could
and if they couldn't
they started to pay more attention to
the idea of school choice that you could
have portable
tax dollars that you could choose to
designate to the school that you want
your child to go to
so i think the more parents are aware of
all of these options the more they might
want to elect someone who
gives them the opportunity to make a
choice one of the most
heated debates around the country and on
capitol hill right now
is about voting rights republican
legislatures have seized on the big lie
to restrict the franchise
senate majority leader chuck schumer
says democrats want to make it easier to
vote
minority leader mitch mcconnell says
it's a power grab
popular safeguards like voter id would
be neutered
ludicrous practices like ballot
harvesting
would be mandatory coast to coast it's a
debate that didn't start with the 2020
election
but has come to a boil since this is an
enormous
issue you had covered voting patterns
where we saw
mail-in voting at levels that we've
never seen in the country before
and extended windows for voting and drop
off mailboxes for voting
all of this was designed because there
was i think a justifiable concern
about having a presidential election in
the middle of a pandemic
so in many ways the rules were changed
around the country
each state handling it the way they saw
fit to make it easier
for people to vote now because
of i think in part because of the
outcome democrats
want to enshrine a lot of those changes
and expand them and republicans have a
fear that
some of these expansions of ability to
vote
opened the window for potential fraud
for instance ballot harvesting if you
can drop off 40 ballots in a box
there's a lack of chain of custody of
the person who
filled out that ballot and means to
vote by it so it's a really important
debate
and it's something that i think all
americans should pay very close
attention to
it's going to have a major impact on
elections to come
that kind of dovetails into the fight
over
stripping congresswoman liz cheney of
her leadership position
in the house as well because she's been
so critical of president trump's
election fraud claims
more broadly how big a problem is that
for the republican party
well i think the feeling is very divided
over this issue and i think there are
understandable arguments on both sides
senator joni ernst said that she sees
the
removal of liz cheney in her leadership
position in the republican party as
cancel culture for her speaking out
about what she sees as the big lie in
terms of
the former president's interpretation of
what happened in the election
and then on the other hand you have
party leaders
such as minority leader mccarthy senator
lindsey graham who i just spoke to about
this
who say there's nothing wrong with
expressing
your opinion about the prior election
but
we need leadership that is going to
unify the party
and they believe that the only way to
success is a trump bust
model where people embrace the trump
voter
and look to add people to the party so
it's
again it's a it's a significant struggle
and i think that democrats will want to
encourage that struggle any division in
the republican party is going to be of
benefit to the
to democrats moving forward so we'll see
how it sorts out
fox's martha mccallum we appreciate you
following it all
and thanks for spending so much time
with us thank you
great to talk to you
this is jim daly with your fox news
commentary coming up
the chinese government used to be so
worried about population growth it had a
one child per couple policy
now they could really use some babies
there new census figures out of china
show population growth basically flat
over the last 10 years
adding around 7 million people per year
with a population now 1.41 billion
that percentage increase is the smallest
since china started conducting a census
in 1953.
berths have fallen four years in a row
12 million last year is the fewest since
1961 after a widespread famine had
killed millions of people
it's unclear what exactly the effect
will be on china's economy or anything
else at least right now
it's still considered the second or
third most powerful country in the world
depending on what you think of russia
there's a status issue when
you recognize that the population that
they have been trying to
expand for some time and they removed
the one child policy at the beginning of
xi jinping's first term
it didn't really make a difference ian
bremer is president and founder of the
eurasia group and the host of g
zero world with ian bremmer on pbs
it's aligned with power status
prestige i mean they have with their
five-year plan
right now they're talking about a dual
circulation policy that is an
orientation towards
greater reliance for growth on their own
domestic market
it's really hard to grow your domestic
market
when your population is flat so it does
have meaning for all of those
reasons but i would caution
about reading too much into it uh yeah
it looks like talking about status it
looks like india will pass them for the
most populous country in i don't know
four or five years
now you mentioned china famously had
this one child policy in place after
decades of exploding population
it became a two-child policy about five
years ago not everybody followed it but
there was
in some cases forced contraception for
sterilization besides the morality of it
uh did the chinese government at some
point really miscalculate regarding
their demographics uh yeah i think they
have
uh for for a long time um you know the
the view uh that a a simple
shift by the government uh into a
pro-natalist stance
without any of the you know economic
or political social support that would
get people to change their behavior
just doesn't move the needle i mean the
only major country around that has
implemented a pro-natalist policy that
really worked
was france and there it was
combined with you know a smaller work
week
with enormous support for maternity
leave
for a whole host of social contract and
spending
that made the average french person feel
like building a family
was a really smart thing to do in china
that that just has never been an
accompanied piece of policy
yeah i mean the birth rate here is
slowed too for some of the same reasons
a lot of people say they're waiting
because they can't afford a big enough
home or they just can't afford a kid in
general they want to get their careers
going and those are the same
concerns that young couples i assume
have in china that's right of course
um and you know again populations have
been leveling off around the world also
as you get wealthier and you get more
educated
the only part of the world that is
experiencing truly explosive growth
right now
is sub-saharan africa and no surprise
it's by far the poorest the least
educated
the most rural and women are in by far
the worst position
as all of those things change with
globalization
and a growing economy you're going to
see population trends in sub-saharan
africa
decline as well how much does population
really matter they certainly have enough
people to have their military and to
have a workforce right
i think that's a big question over the
last 50 years
you weren't going to experience growth
unless you had more people in your
population because that was how you
drove capital was you needed a labor
force in fact china's been
the factory for global manufacturing
but you know you know in the united
states
increasingly if you don't have a college
degree there isn't work
for you well that's happening all over
the world with
automation and robotics and artificial
intelligence
and even though china's workforce is
really flattening it's plateauing and it
will decrease
china's data explosion bigger than that
of any other country in the world is
only continuing to expand and if it
turns out that you don't need as much
working labor
but what you really do need is data that
you can mine
and exploit and make profit out of well
there the chinese are not only number
one in the world right now
but that gap is actually expanding so i
think there's a big
uncertainty around to what extent
population
is going to continue to be the primary
driver
of a country's power china has a huge
propaganda operation running
in the u.s right what's its goal and
what can or should we
do about it their goal has been
less about breaking things in the u.s
and trying to exploit u.s internal
divisions the russians have done more of
that
it's more trying to promote patriotism
and chinese political goals so they want
americans of chinese descent to be more
supportive
of beijing less of taiwan
or hong kong they want more
alignment with china's success in being
able to beat back coronavirus for
example
they want to undermine uh american
narratives
uh that go after china for the initial
cover-up of coronavirus for intellectual
property theft for
the weaker issues and let's face it
right now the united states not only
mistrust
china but we disagree with china on
serious
issues that in in almost every aspect
where the two countries come together
chinese state-directed propaganda and
they're spending a lot more money on
that about 500 percent
more than this last year than they did
the year before
that is all orienting at countering that
narrative
yeah well the narrative here and maybe
it's different in national philosophies
is that people in taiwan people in hong
kong should be free
and there the narrative is that no they
should be part of our great nation of
china will taiwan and hong kong even be
independent in a few years if you can
say you know to the extent that they are
now
hong kong is not independent uh hong
kong uh the idea
of one state and two systems has been
unilaterally abrogated by the chinese
communist party
there is no more democracy in hong kong
free speech and freedom of press has
been fundamentally eroded
so has rule of law hong kong's economic
capabilities are still very strong
because they're getting integrated into
a very robust and much
larger mainland chinese economy but you
can no longer say that there's
meaningful freedom in hong kong taiwan
is still very much independent and even
though the united states does not
formally recognize it as a separate
state the united states does provide
lots of defense capacity so that
taiwanese can defend themselves
against mainland china and can maintain
rule of law
and a separate political system and for
now
that continues to persist but certainly
over time that is a major flash point
between the us and china
yeah we hear about the civil rights
abuses the lack of labor protections in
china was it always
a myth that china was eventually going
to become this you know freer capitalist
society was that just
was that something that's been curtailed
or was it never to be
uh it was never to be that as the
chinese got wealthier that they were
going to become american
it was never to be that they were going
to implement democracy
or a free market they need heavy capital
controls to keep the chinese from taking
their cash
out of the country and the chinese
economy is run largely by the state they
are the
most important economic actor in the
united states that's the private sector
so it's a very different system there
have been meaningful reforms in china
over the last decades and that has led
um to a flourishing of
many not just uh you know multinational
corporations in the us making a lot of
money in china but also china's
china's own private sector that does
operate at least somewhat independently
from the communist party
but under xi jinping who is by far the
strongest
leader that china's had since mao i
would argue there's been more
consolidation
of control there has been less freedom
for people like jack ma for example who
has you know basically been
seriously punished for uh trying to act
independently from the chinese
leadership
um i would argue that uh there's
they ended term limits for the chinese
president if anything there's been a bit
of backsliding
but china was never going to be an open
free market democracy that
that that was a presumption made by the
foreign policy establishment in the
united states
for many decades republicans and
democrats and a mistaken one
yeah well we probably just in the way
that we do thought well
everybody wants to be a american
eventually we've thought the same thing
about the soviet
union yeah i mean and that's not a very
credible thing to say right i mean
especially given what's happened in the
united states i mean the events of
january 6 the massive divisions in this
country the fact that a majority of
people that voted for trump believe that
the election was stolen by biden
i mean the united states is not very
legitimate
at promoting a free market and a
representative democracy i mean canada
would be more effective germany would be
more effective japan would be more
effective the problem is those countries
aren't very powerful
the united states is by far the most
powerful even if it's less legitimate
in terms of its democracy and so it it
that does erode
america's soft power and its ability to
provide
a road map both for allies more aligned
with the united states
and for you know adversaries who are
basically saying ha
united states look at you you have no
moral authority to tell us what to do
finally ian coronavirus more than a year
ago
you're on the show talking about how
little credibility they have
on the issue they still really do is
that the kind of thing that could hurt
their world influence or does
their money and military power just
trump all that oh no it hurts them a lot
the fact that the chinese lied about the
initial human to human transfer of
coronavirus
is a massive delegitimizer
of the chinese government the fact that
their vaccines
don't work very well and they've not
been transparent
with the international community or with
their own people
is a serious problem the united states
is now positioned to have the most
effective vaccine diplomacy
with the best vaccines and the most
vaccines to export
in the world in short order in the next
couple of months and that is a
significant american advantage vis-a-vis
china i mean it's true that countries
don't trust the americans
as much as they did 20 or 30 years ago
but it's also true that they trust the
americans a lot more than they trust the
chinese
and that persists if anything
coronavirus has expanded that gap
ian bremer's president and founder of
the eurasia group he's the host of gzero
world with
ian bremmer on pbs ian thanks for coming
on the fox news rundown great
from the fox news podcasts network i'm
ben dominic publisher of the federalists
and i'm inviting you to join a new
conversation with the smartest thinkers
out there about the country and where
we're going subscribe to the ben dominic
podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcasts.com
it's time for your fox news commentary
jim daly
what's on your mind many on the left
today want to muzzle conservative
christians and even if you're not a
religious person
that should worry you i remember being
in moscow back in august of 1991
when president mikhail gorbachev was put
under house arrest
it was a failed coup attempt
orchestrated by hardline communists in
the soviet union's government
and their military leadership at the
time residents were being told that mr
gorbachev was ill
in reality he was being held hostage but
glimpses of truth began leaking out
western news reports were being
plastered all over the walls of moscow
a great buzz began spreading in the
streets as people in the city heard the
news and read it
i've seen it elsewhere too i've been in
several authoritarian countries where
government officials monitored the
christian church very closely
and allowed them only limited freedoms i
was told by christians in those
countries that the communist government
would only tolerate so much before
cracking down
and silencing any expression of faith i
was curious and asked them why
the answer was always the same these
christians would say
it's because the party fears the power
of the church
the communist party wants to be the only
power people are allowed to follow
sadly i believe i'm seeing the same
trend in the united states today
with increasing frequency progressives
say they don't want religion in the
public square
big tech wants to edit what religious
leaders can say
what's happening it's obvious to many of
us that left-leaning thought leaders in
our country's power centers like
educators political and business leaders
and sports organizations are trying to
ensure that religious expression
doesn't challenge the state's
ideological narrative or their power
in other words the values imposed by
politicians and their allies
must be followed period this sounds
eerily
similar to what my christian friends
describe in totalitarian countries
from bakers and florists to faith-based
adoption services
tolerance for christians and their
conservative beliefs
have tanked to all-time lows people who
support beliefs in the bible are being
targeted
it's breathtaking to watch your culture
flip so quickly
ancient truths that have helped
establish our nation as the most
prosperous
innovative generous and vibrant are now
being tipped upside down
to pursue hate division grievances and
other destructive paths as a christian i
embrace what the apostle paul stated
when he declared
our citizenship is in heaven it's not
here
yes we give to caesar what is caesar's
but we ultimately answer to god
not government and i believe god's laws
trump any earthly edict yet this first
devotion is neither problematic
nor something to fear unless those in
power want to force people of faith
to violate their conscience and deeply
held convictions
that's because committed christians make
excellent citizens
always looking to serve others and point
people to the world yet to come
this is jim daly president of focus on
the family
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news
go to foxnews.com
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on
american life politics and entertainment
subscribe now
on foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts